in your studies about what animals do
and working to relate that to humans
there's a language that some animals use
that maybe we're just beginning to
understand dolphins elephants
Simeon's whatever the family would be so
for making our judgments our analysis on
their actions of their activities are we
missing something or we have yet to
learn more about their language about me
maybe indicating something more that's
going on
great what I would say at this point is
what's known about some spectacular
subtle communication systems and other
species ranging from elephants
communicating to each other by the
vibration from their footsteps - you
know electric fish that court other
electric fish with electric songs things
of that sort
you know amid all that complexity there
are two things we do that no other
species does we can communicate about
absolutely abstract states we can talk
about existentialism and chimps as far
as we know don't or we can accept this
same over-the-top emotional expressions
that all sorts of other species have but
we can do that talking about events that
occurred 2,000 years ago or events
occurring on the other side of the
planet so we can have far more abstract
language or we can use our most
emotional you know anger works and thus
just like in every other species but in
very abstract context that seems
absolutely unique on the other hand
everybody in the field fifty years ago
would have had all sorts of things
listed or unique to us that no longer
are so maybe stay tuned